I've always been an admirer of animation
it's an art form where literally
anything is possible as someone who is
on the autism spectrum there are certain
things that I struggle with I figured
that working in the field that I have so
much love for was nothing more than like
a a pipe dream to feel like I've been
given this opportunity to prove myself
it's such a amazing experience my name
is David miles I'm a junior VFX artist
and animator here at exceptional minds
except for mines is this amazing school
for young adults on the autism spectrum
we teach them visual effects in
animation students go through a three
year program where they learn the basics
of animation and visual effects and then
they learn compositing and editing so
that they know how to tell a story the
vast majority of people with autism have
extreme trouble finding work we're
trying to create a place where people
can take advantage of their talents and
they can reach great heights I'm going
to be starting an internship at Cartoon
Network which I'm incredibly excited
about knowing that I can make a career
out this is probably one of the biggest
reliefs one of the best feelings that I
have ever experienced one of the things
I've discovered being around other
people who are on the autism spectrum is
that there is such a great variety of
personality of creative potential I've
seen people who can do absolutely
mind-blowing things with special effects
with animation there is a certain
advantage to being able to think very
differently from the typical person
you